[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: We couldn't
get enough of him.
So we brought him back.
Joining us once more is Kelsey
Hightower, developer advocate
at Google Cloud.
Kelsey, talk to us about
how serverless solutions
help developers.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yes, so I think
serverless solutions for
people new to serverless,
it's kind of like we've
learned a lot of patterns
from four or five
years of Kubernetes.
And all the things you need to
do to provide that higher level
interface that you give
all your developers
or that you enjoy working
with every day, that's where
serverless attempts to start.
So we take some
of those patterns
and we give people the smallest
interface that they want to do.
So if you think about if a file
gets uploaded to a Google Cloud
Storage bucket, you can just
invoke your business logic
and execute your code for you.
STEPHANIE WONG: Now,
people want serverless,
but they also want containers.
How is Google
enabling developers
to have both the
velocity of serverless
and the flexibility
of containers?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
That's the thing
that I'm probably
the most proud of.
So when serverless is most
introduced for first introduced
to most people, they
always thought about it
as functions as a service.
You write a single
function, an event
comes in, it calls
your function.
But there's a lot
of existing business
logic that needs
a little bit more
than just a single function.
Maybe there's some
bootstrapping code.
You got a set of
things like logging,
but a little bit
more flexibility
and your choice of runtime.
So what we decided to do was
take a lot of the learnings
from Kubernetes and allow
developers to deploy
their own Docker container.
So any runtime that you want
to use, any business logic
that you want, any
libraries, and we're
going to execute that container
just like we do with our Cloud
Function.
So they scale to zero.
They scale up quick.
And they give you the
same serverless workflow
that you're used to without
abandoning all the good things
that come with containers.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
So you've talked a little
bit about serverless
isn't brand new, but we're
changing the way that we're
sort of approaching it.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about how Google is changing
that serverless experience?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
So I think, for us,
is that our DNA has always
been around this idea
of this kind of software
delivery chain, right?
So this idea that when
you build a software,
we like to build it once,
we sign those images,
and then we decide where we
want them to be deployed.
So that means giving
people a bit of choice.
So typically,
serverless has been
kind of these proprietary
cloud platforms.
Once you're in there,
you're kind of locked in.
What we decided to do is make
sure that it runs everywhere.
So wherever you as
a developer want
to run, just like most
Google tools and libraries,
we allow our serverless stack
to run wherever you are.
So I think what we're
doing different here
is taking some of the
things that worked well
in the Kubernetes space
and combining them
with some of the
developer experiences
that we know that
people are looking for.
And it's combining the two.
So flexibility without losing
the tradeoffs and benefits
of going serverless.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's great.
So how does our serverless
offering help our developers,
and how is it different?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
I think where it's
different is that you get to
use a familiar tool chain that
has been popularized over the
last couple of years, right?
So containers are
the way most people
think about having full control
over their own software.
Then to be able to
take that software
and outsource all of
the delivery, right?
So security, IEM
integration, being
able to connect to things
like Spanner and BigQuery,
taking all of that kind
of toil away from you,
and just say, hey,
checking your containers,
and we'll run them for you.
So what we're
trying to do is kind
of make it very seamless
from a developer.
Once you go from
idea to deployed,
we're just trying to give
you that same GCP experience
at the container level.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Now how do our
serverless offerings
give developers a more
open and portable offering
so that customers
can potentially
move their workloads around?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So
one thing-- the trend
that has been really prevalent
in GCP is in Kubernetes,
we started with Docker, popular
open source container runtime,
and then we shipped an
open source project,
Kubernetes, which is the
underlying platform for GKE.
And then when we thought
about entering serverless,
so we've had App Engine for
it for almost 11 years now.
And we decided that let's--
what would we do if we wanted
to make App Engine
to be more open?
So we decided to start
with the Knative project.
So Knative has a lot of
serverless components.
You can think of it as a
serverless toolkit, things
like bills, a
function framework.
And most of that stuff is
laid on top of Kubernetes.
So what we've done is
we've taken the best
parts of Kubernetes--
again, those design patterns
that we talked about.
How do I just run
my application?
We've extracted that out into
a high level set of libraries
called Knative.
And there's a hosted
version we call Cloud Run.
And we also give you the ability
to run Cloud Run on top of GKE.
So the benefit
there is that if you
need to do some
machine learning,
you can take that
serverless workload
and run it on a specialized
VM with a GPU or TPU.
So you're no longer restricted
to just our serverless
runtime environments.
You now have the whole of
GCP opened up to you, even
in the serverless context.
STEPHANIE WONG: And you
touched on this a bit.
But a lot of our
customers tell us
that they have
custom requirements,
like specific run
times, custom binaries,
or workload portability.
And more often
than not, they turn
to containers for an answer.
Can you talk about
how RGKE serverless
add-on allows you to bring
serverless to containers?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes.
So when you think about--
a lot of these abstractions
change over time.
We went from mainframe,
to physical machines,
to virtualization, to
higher level platforms,
like App Engine.
What we now have with the
container image, this ability
to build a code that you want,
use the runtime that you want,
any version that you want--
and now that becomes
a portable bit.
You can run this on
a virtual machine.
You can run this on GKE.
You can run this on Cloud Run.
And you can also run
it on App Engine.
So I think what
the developer gets
is this ability to
truly write once
and deploy wherever they want.
RETO MEIER: Now,
while we believe
Google Cloud is a great place
to run all types of workloads,
some customers,
we know that they
need to run on-premises or
across multiple clouds, right?
So tell us a little
bit more about Knative
and its role in
giving developers
the freedom to move stateless
containers pretty much
anywhere?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yeah, so our
contribution to the ecosystem
started with maybe
Kubernetes, right?
So Kubernetes, over the
four or five years--
you can see it now--
it's deployed and offered
by every major cloud provider.
Lots of people are already
running it on-prem.
So it has wide adoption.
So our strategy of
layering Knative
on top of Kubernetes,
this allows us
to kind of reap those benefits.
So the tools that
you're familiar with,
we layer Knative on top.
So that gives us that
portability framework
underneath.
So, no matter where
you're running,
whether it's on-prem, different
cloud provider, on GCP,
you can get the
same APIs, right?
So we talked earlier about
automating those APIs, that's
what Kubernetes represents.
And I've always said this.
Kubernetes is a platform
for building platforms.
And we've chosen to build
our newest serverless
platforms on top of Kubernetes.
STEPHANIE WONG: Can you
talk a little bit more
about how Knative provides
inventing and integrating
events from Google or
third party services
so you can really extend
your applications?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So the big
thing to know about Knative,
it's not just Google's
project, right?
So now we have so
many contributors--
Red Hat, Cloud Foundry.
So a lot of the
things that we've
seen in the eventing space,
like what is an event,
how should we accept it, a
lot of those open protocols,
like Cloud Events, all of
that's supported inside Knative.
So Knative gives you a
couple of components.
We call Knative serving.
Run my container.
Scale it to zero.
Start it again when
a request comes in.
Then you have the
event team piece.
So there's an event.
And what we wanted to do
is make an event portable.
So different cloud providers
has a different collection
of events, different
transports for events.
So we wanted to do is make sure
that the event framework was
very flexible.
If you want to
integrate with GitHub,
or GCP, or some other
service that you have
that you've defined yourself,
that's also included.
So what we've done is we've
given all of these framework
pieces, and what we've
done with Cloud Run is
we've kind of curated the
perfect stack for you.
RETO MEIER: Great.
And is there a
particular way in which
we're able to solve that
problem that you describe,
as like having all
of these things
leading to all of
these different places?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Yes,
so I think for us is,
Kubernetes is super flexible.
So what that flexibility
allows every cloud provider
to do their own integrations.
For example,
on-prem, we come out
of the gate integrating with
things like with VMware and F5.
So we abstract away
some of the differences
between all of these platforms.
So that's what
Kubernetes' job is.
Once you have that
set of abstractions,
things like Knative
just sit on top
and naively assume that
those abstractions are there
and that we can get on with
building those higher level
platforms.
So Kubernetes is a
huge part of this.
And the community has
been doing this work
for over four years
of abstracting away
the differences between
these cloud providers.
So whenever you
build on top of that,
we just inherit all
of those benefits.
STEPHANIE WONG: Well,
thank you so much again
for joining us today, Kelsey.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Awesome.
Thanks for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]